bienvenue à tous c'est l'heure de
Parlement Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique avec
Marion bonjour mariononour vous allez
bien avec notre invité également Bruno
lurou bonjour bonjour président du
groupe socialiste à l'Assemblée
nationale on va regarder les titres de
l'actualité ensemble cette semaine les
premiers pas du nouveau Premier ministre
à l'Assemblée nationale discours de
politique générale la majorité lui a
voté sa confiance dans la foulée suite
et fin du remanement 14 secrétaires
d'État ont été nommés ils sont 30 au
total les réactions au retrait de la vie
politique de Jean-Louis borlau pour
raisons de santé sont nombreuses et
unanimes toutes salue une voix originale
et un homme imaginatif qui va manquer à
l'UDI la bataille pour sa succession a
déjà commencé et que se passe-t-il dans
la tête de françois hollande c'est le
titre d'un documentaire diffusé sur
France 3 en début de semaine portrait
psychologique du président notre invité
proche parmi les proches de François
Hollande pourra peut-être répondre à
cette question c'est le plus de
l'bdo mais on commence cette édition par
le décès de Dominique budis il s'est
éteint jeudi à l'âge de 66 ans défendeur
des droits ancien maire de Toulouse il a
été l'une des figures du centre avec
Pierre megeri et Jacques barraau son nom
reste aussi associé à la terrible rumeur
dont il fut victime en 2003 dans
l'affaire Allègre il avait présidé le
comité éditorial du Figaro le Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel puis
l'Institut du monde arabe avant de
devenir Défenseur des droits il a
également été députés national et
européens jusqu'en
2011 Bruno lerou
j'imagine tristesse à l'annonce oui bien
entendu tristesse parce que d'abord nous
l'avions côtoyé ces dernières années
dans ces différentes responsabilités et
parce que c'était un un humaniste c'est
quelqu'un qui avait toujours dans sa
gestion municipale bien entendu mais
ensuite dans la façon dont il relatait
l'actualité dont il a défendu ensuite
comme défendeur des droits avec une
pratique qui a été une pratique de
proximité c'est quelqu'un de de
particulièrement humaniste on a toujours
tendance à à relever les personnalités
atypiques il faisait partie de ces
personnalités atypiques un début de
semaine politique qui a également été
marqué par l'annonce du retrait de la
vie politique de Jean-Louis
borlot
il préfère se retirer Jean-Louis borlau
tourne la page de ses années politique
pour des raisons de santé et il a rendu
tous ses mandats son départ ému la
classe politique et bien sûr les
centriste prépare sa succession Thomas
soulier
ou on regarde on sourit difficile pour
eux de décrocher en sourire au lendemain
du renoncement de Jean-Louis borlot les
centristes ont la gueule de bois
officiellement réunis pour lancer les
européennes tous ne parlent que de
l'après borlau qui pour succéder au
leader naturel officiellement l'heure
n'est pas aux ambitions personnelles la
consigne est claire ne pas donner une
mauvaise image du parti à 50 jours du
scrutin
européen il est pas question d'ego la
guerre des chefs est pas déclarée et
puis s'il y avait une guerre des chefs
je pense que c'est pas du tout dans
l'esprit même de l'UDI aujourd'hui donc
ce serait le premier à se déclarer sera
certainement la première victime on a
des exemples à ne pas suivre c'est le
congrès de re du Parti socialiste c'est
l'UMP avec Jean-François Copé contre
François Fillon il faut qu'on fasse le
contraire mais en coulisse on s'agite
des premières ambitions et des premières
tensions le nouveau président devrait
être désigné à la fin de l'année et ce
par les militants mais certains veulent
aller vite pour éviter des mois de
corelles
internes par définition ce genre
d'élection est parfois source de tension
de rivalité c'est bien naturel et moi
j'ai appris pour en avoir vu d'autres au
sein d'un parti politique que plus c'est
long plus c'est con plus il y a de
tension le président par intérim de
l'UDI devrait être désigné demain soir
Yv Diego fait figure de favoris au
Palais Bourbon il faudra attendre le
mardi 15 avril François sauadé devrait
succéder à Jean-Louis borlot à la tête
du groupe udi à l'Assemblée alors
Jean-Louis brlot c'était un député
charismatique est-ce qu'il va manquer au
débat à l'Assemblée nationale ah oui
comment pourrait-il en être autrement et
moi j'ai souligné cette semaine que la
pudeur je pense est une qualité en
politique et qu'il en avait beaucoup
dans une lettre qui était une lettre
très digne dans une décision qui est une
décision très forte et ce que je
souhaite véritablement parce qu'on a
choisi on a compris qu'il avait choisi
un autre combat qu'il avait un autre
combat à mener moi j'espère que toute
l'énergie qui quelquefois déborde un peu
à l'Assemblée nationale nous allons lui
en donner une partie pour ce que nous
lui devons et que nous allons lui donner
l'énergie de gagner le combat qu'il est
en train de mener aujourd'hui comme il a
gagné beaucoup de combats auparavant il
y a un membre de l'UMP qui a dit cette
semaine avec D Jean-Luc borlot la classe
politique la politique serait
complètement différente vous êtes
d'accord là encore les personnalité
atypique n'arrivve dans leur camp qu'à
émerger dans ce qu'on appelle le centre
on parlait tout à l'heure de ce camp qui
n'existe pas politiquement mais qui est
incarné par de grandes personnalités
depuis de très nombreuses années vous
citiez le Canu vous ctiz un certain
nombre de responsables tout à l'heure je
crois que Jean-Louis borlot avait choisi
un positionnement qui faisait que son
côté j'agite un petit peu tout et je
regarde ce que cela donne ne se retrouve
pas clairement avec qui vous auriez pu
travailler vous AZ pu travailler dans
l'opposition mais moi je me souviens que
entre 1997 et 2002 quand Jean-Louis
borlot était dans l'opposition à de
multiples reprises nous avons travaillé
avec lui il a accompagné les jeunes
parlementaires dont j'étais dans des
initiatives communes et depuis je
regardais ce qu'il faisait sans a priori
il a su faire des choses qui étaient
très partisanes quand il a été en
responsabil en même temps il avait une
personnalité qui l'amenait forcément à
essayer d'élargir le cercle rou je vous
propose d'attaquer un petit peu à partir
du mardi il y a les gros dossiers en
tout cas pour votre majorité discours de
politique général pour le nouveau
Premier
ministre alors ne vous inquiétez pas on
va parler du fond bien évidemment mais
d'abord je voudrais qu'on s'attarde un
petit peu sur la forme de ce discours 47
minutes manuel Vals a donné le ton pour
le moins différent de celui de son ses
prédécesseurs c'est mir aussi qui vous
explique tout ça pour son baptême du feu
devant les députés manuel Vals se pose
comme celui qui regarde la réalité en
face une réalité difficile le Premier
ministre qui veut adresser un discours
de vérité n lut pas les crises et les
doutes qui traversent le pays trop de
souffrance pas assez d'espérance telle
est la situation de la France mais pas
question de se focaliser sur la face
sombre du pays il a tenté d'insuffler
une dose d'espoir en le génie français
ne rétrécissons pas la France ne
rétrécissons pas ses rêves et je vous
demande le cœur battant pour la France
de m'accorder votre confiance attendu
par une opposition très remuante manuel
Vals a tout de même tendu la main à la
droite en proposant de recevoir ses
chefs de fil mais cet après-midi c'est
surtout son camp qu'il devait convaincre
je connais les attentes de la majorité
parlementaire je les partage et je veux
travailler avec elle
équbr n engageellement dans cet exercice
solenneluel filtr une part d'émotion en
éant son parcours de catalan naturalis
à imm honneur pour moi je dis qu'il y a
peu de pays au monde qui
permett citoy à
l'étrangurs rép
plusut à une France plus forte et plus
juste sa feuille de route est maintenant
tracée à lui de conduire son
gouvernement vers cet objectif si je
vous demande ce que vous avez le plus
apprécié dans ce discours j'imagine que
vous allez me dire à peu près tout mais
qu'est-ce que vous n'avez pas aimé s'il
y a quelque chose que vous n'avez pas
aimé non non dans un discours tel que
celui-ci je cru que vous alleiez me
demander en un mot de caractériser le
discours je vous aurz dit l'énergie don
on a besoin mais il n'y a pas j'essaie
de comprendre ce qui ce qui peut-être ne
va pas donc
non non dans un discours tel que
celui-ci non je pourrais vous dire par
une espèce de closeuse de style que il a
été trop court euh qu'il aurait pu aller
mais oui mais qu'en même temps on lui a
dit vous n'avez pas parlé de ça et vous
n'avez pas été l'xum mais il a essayé
pas faire un catalogue non plus non
justement il voulait donner de l'énergie
à son propos et il voulait tracer les
enjeux essentiels pour le pays et dire
en quoi son gouvernement mais aussi la
personnalité qui était la sienne dont on
a vu à la fin que elle était très
particulière dans ce que vit la
République aujourd'hui ce parcours qui
est celui de quelqu'un qui a choisi la
République épousé la République et donc
j'ai trouvé ce discours en même temps
plein d'énergie mais surtout prometteur
et il a demandé aux Français la
mobilisation c'est peut-être ce que l'on
a espéré de mieux aujourd'hui oui bien
entendu suffisamment
oui euh et dans le même temps il faudra
maintenant dans chacun des textes qui
arrivent convaincre que ce que nous ont
dit les électeurs que le sentiment qu'il
n'y avait pas assez d'équilibre qu'il
n'y avait pas assez de place à la
justice nous allons pouvoir le
réintroduire mais oui dans les mesures
quand il annonce bien entendu la
poursuite de la politique de
redressement d'amélioration de notre
compétitivité mais qu'il dit les
entreprises c'est aussi les salariés et
ces salariés il faut aussi qu'ils aient
des conséquences en matière de pouvoir
d'achat je pense que c'est des mots que
nous n'avons pas assez employés
auparavant peut-être une politique que
nous n'avons pas assez mise en œuvre et
qui est le résultat de ce que nous ont
dit aussi les Français dans ce singlant
euh cette s défaite que nous avons connu
aux élections municipales on a vu un
manuel Vals qui veut apaiser qui veut
rassembler c'est fini le manuel Vals
clivant et quand on est premier ministre
on a forcément une responsabilité qui
est différente lui-même l'a dit
d'ailleurs il s'est construit ces
dernières années avec un certain nombre
d'idées qui était les siennes qu'il
défendait qui lui servait à provoquer le
débat aujourd'hui il est le premier
ministre pour la capacité à animer une
équipe a essayé de mobiliser les
françaisu oui mais dans le même temps ce
n'est pas un premier ministre qui est en
décalage avec la majorité et le
président de la République il met en
œuvre la politique du président de la
République c'est pas ce qu'on a cru
comprendre sur les certains bans du
Parti socialiste dans certain l' gauche
en tout cas du PS mais mais mais c'est
pour ça que cette lecture est une
mauvaise lecture quand on veut qualifier
le manuel Vals d'aujourd'hui en
reprenant les propos qu'il y avait il y
a plusieurs mois ou plusieurs années on
oublie que l'élection présidentielle est
passée par là on oublie que le Président
de la République l'a nommé après sêtre
adressé aux Français c'est-à-dire avoir
dressé une feuille de route et la
feuille de route de Manuel Val
aujourd'hi c'est la feille de route de
jean-marquerot c'est la même oui avec
les résultats des élections municipales
qui est passé par là si vous me dites ce
que c'est la poursuite du redressement
oui c'est la poursuite du redressement
est-ce que c'est un nouvel équilibre
aujourd'hui entre ce redressement et les
attentes sociales des Français oui aussi
et peut-être que cela nous ne l'avons
pas assez prise en compte ces derniers
mois et alors justement on va passer au
fond et c'est l'économie qui a largement
dominé ce discours de politique et
générale manuel valsa a détaillé le
pacte de responsabilité baisse du coût
du travail allègement de charg et baisse
des cotisations sociales tous les
détails avec ellisa
bertholomé trop de
souffrance pas assez d'espérance telle
est la situation de la France constat
pessimiste en ouverture du discours de
politique générale de Manuel Vals mais
le nouveau Premier ministre espère bien
régler cette situation avec un programme
économique précis premier axe le pacte
de
responsabilité il faut alléger le coût
du travail il doit baisser c'est un des
leviers de la compétitivité pas le seul
mais il pèse lourd mesure immédiate la
mise en place d'une politique de zéro
charge pour l'employeur lorsqu'un
salarié est payé au smic dès le 1er
janvier 2015 mais aussi baisse des
cotisations familles pour les
travailleurs indépendants et pour les
salaires jusqu'à trois fois et demi le
SMIC pour relancer l'investissement le
gouvernement agira sur la fiscale des
entreprises le taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés sera abaissé à 28 % d'ici 2020
au total l'effort de l'État s'élèvera à
30 milliards d'euros un geste sera fait
en faveur des salariés c'est le pacte de
solidarité le gouvernement veut
améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des plus
modestes en agissant sur les cotisations
salariales dès le 1er janvier 2015 elles
seront diminuées pour les salaires au
niveau du SMIC pour procurer € par an de
salaire net supplémentairire c'est
presque la moitié d'un 13e mois 2è axe
du gouvernement Vals redresser notre
économie 50 milliards d'euros d'économie
sur 3 ans de 2015 à 2017 l'effort sera
l'effort doit être partagé par tous si
les députés d'opposition regrette
l'imprécision du Premier ministre les
socialistes applaudissent un discours
énergique qui piquit toute la caisse des
collectivités locales sur l'état je sais
pas où il économise les 50 milliards
j'ai bien peur que ça se transforme en
impôt pour les Français nulle part le
Premier ministre n indiquer comment il
allait financer ça et en même temps
tenir des objectifs de de réduction de
nos déficit d'équilibre de nos finances
publiqu quis sont obligatoire qui
doivent être tenus sinon c'est la
souveraineté française qui est mise en
cause ce discours qui est fait d'énergie
de volonté voilà nous redonne un peu du
du moral du souffle et Dieu sait si on
en a besoin le calendrier qui attend les
députés est serré certaines de ces ces
mesures seront discutées dès cet été
dans la loi de finan
rectificative on va s'intéresser à toute
cette page économique c'est le zoom de
la
semaine et nous accueillons Jean-Louis
Gombau bonjour Jean-Louis spécialiste
des questions économiques vous avez vu
des bonnes choses et aussi des mauvaises
commençons par les bonnes peut-être
commençons par les bonnes ben les bonnes
monsieur lerou les a dit tout à l'heure
c'est c'est l'énergie et la volonté
justement je crois que dans cette dans
ce discours la prise de conscience par
le Président de la République Monsieur
Vals aussi de la gravité de la crise à
moins que ce soit la prise de conscience
que c'était le moment de mettre vraiment
les choses sur la table la politique
c'est un peu comme la stratégie
militaire savoir exactement choisir le
bon moment où il faut dire les choses et
il faut se rendre compte de l'ampleur de
ce qu'a annoncé le Premier ministre lors
de son discours de politique général
c'est très important vous avez tout le
bilan vous avez fait j'ai j'ai tout le
bilan éidemment pas pas tout le bilan
dans le détail mais vous avez les 50
milliards d'économie et vous avez les 43
milliards de baisse de prélèvement vous
êtes donc sur des masses qui sont
considérables vous êtes autour de 100
milliards c'est-à-dire autour de 5 % du
PIB de la France qui doit bouger d'une
manière ou d'une autre sur les trois
prochaines années d'abord les
prélèvements sur les entreprises
essentiellement vous avez 43 milliards
de baisses de prélèvement soit fiscaux
soit sociaux et autrement dit la gauche
annule passe l'éponge sur les hausses
sur les entreprises qui avaient décidé
la droite puis la gauche elle-même qui
est au total avoisiné les 30 milliards
d'euros là on est sur 43 milliards
d'euros donc on retourne avant si vous
voulez le point de départ et c'est une
baisse des prélèvements globaux sur les
entreprises de l'ordre de 20 % par
rapport à ce qu'ell payent aujourd'hui
mais le plus important c'est évidemment
les baisses de charges sociales nous
sommes sur si on compte cice plus ce que
nous a annoncé le Premier ministre lundi
dernier nous sommes sur une trentaine de
milliards d'euros ce qui est également
absolument considérraable
parce que si vous voulez ça fait ça
contribue à une baisse du coût du
travail de l'ordre de 4
% pas été chiffré je pense que c'est
important de lire parce que et si vous
ajoutez les conséquences de la loi à
c'est qui était voté en janvier 2013 et
je sais que pour les journalistes et
souvent pour les hommes politiques une
loi chasse l'autre on arrive à une
baisse quand les entreprises qui ont
appliqué l'an sur la flexis sécurité je
pense à Bosch je pense à Renault je
pense à PSA je pense à Sevel Nord au
chantier de l'Atlantique ils ont
organisé avec l'accord syndical une
baisse du coût du travail de l'ordre de
5 % donc vous Azé les T 5 % plus 4 % en
1 an la gauche a organisé une baisse peu
d'ici à 2017 une baisse de 10 % du coût
du travail ce qui ne s'est jamais vu
dans l'histoire économique récentou il y
a quand même on a été cherché il y a des
bonnes nouvelles et c'est confirmé par
Jean-Lou Gombau mainant on peut
peut-être s'intéresser à ce qui ne va
pas je vais écouter avec attention alors
ce qui ne va pas c'est plutôt
l'imprécision ça a été dit par un député
juste à l'insant autant c'est très
précis sur les baisses de prélèvement
fiscaux et sociaux autant c'est imprécis
encore sur les problèmes des dépenses 50
milliards d'euros et quelque part il
divrait notre député je crois que
c'était quelqu'un de l'UDI je n'en suis
pas sûr c'est bon et donc autant il div
vrai là-dessus c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
compte ce qui n'est vraiment précis
c'est les baisses de dotation en
collectivité territoriale 10 milliards
c'est très simple à comprendre on baisse
la dotation c'est simple à faire c'est
pas compliqué et ainsi que sans doute
les baisses aux opérateurs de l'État
c'est 40 milliards par an quand même et
là on va baisser donc là aussi c'est
assez simple mais quand on nous dit je
vais faire x milliards d'économie sur la
dépense de santé c'est une évaluation
c'est une hypothèse ce n'est pas des
choses très concrètes donc là il faut
attendre et puis il y a un deuxième
aspect pour terminer c'est au niveau
microéconomique oui j'espère bien c'est
au niveau microéconomique si vous
additionnez l'ensemble des mesures de
baisse de charge sociale en France on a
arrive à une construction d'une
complexité absolument incroyable vous
avez les allègements fillons autour de
20 milliards d'euros c'està-dire 12 % au
niveau du SMIC dégrevé jusqu'à 1,6 Smic
là vous organisez un nouveau système
zéro charge URSAF au niveau du SMIC
jusqu'à également 1,6 donc les deux
systèmes vont se superposer sur le cice
vous avez 4 à 6 % de baisse de la masse
salariale brute mais jusqu'à 2,5 SMIC et
puis vous introduisez un nouvel système
sur les allocations familiales vous AZ
avz là jusqu'à 3,5 SMIC comment on va
faire une fiche de P oui la question
n'est pas anodine surtout au moment où
nous avons des missions et je parle
notamment du travail excellent que fait
tiierry Mandon pour la simplification
aujourd'hui de tout ce que sont les
normes et les règlementations qui
s'appliquent aux entreprises mais dans
le même temps ce que vous montrez là
c'est que quand on veut être juste et
quand on veut rentrer dans le détail
c'est vrai qu'on peut créer une forme de
complexité manuel Val l'a assumé dès son
discours la question du coût du travail
il a dit que le coût du travail et c'est
vrai qu'on on a des débats depuis
plusieurs années sur est-ce que c'est
véritablement le coût du travail est-ce
que c'est oui la France elle a d'autres
atouts que le coût du travail elle a
l'atout de sa formation elle a l'atout
de l'aménagement de son territoire des
services qui sont logistiques mais elle
a un problème et on pouvait pas le
cacher on pouvait pas continuer à dire
que cela n'existait pas oui cela existe
et quand l'on veut faire œuvre de
compétitivité il fallait prendre des
décisions cela a été clairement assumé
par le Premier ministre ensuite je ne
veux pas reprendre tout ce que vous avez
donné mais je suis d'accord avec vous
répond à sur ce qui ne va pas oui je
voudrais surtout répondre à ce qui ne va
pas je ne voudrais pas ajouter à ce qui
allait C c'était pas tant une question
de flou parce qu'il n'y aura pas
longtemps à attendre mais moi je
voudrais dire que les annonces qui ont
été faites de dépenses ou plutôt
d'allègement qu'il va falloir financer
des cotisations pour les entreprises et
pour les particuliers il n'y a qu'une
seule voix pour les réussir c'est la
voix des économies parce que là où
Jean-Christophe laard avait raison et là
où je veux démentir tout de suite c'est
qu'il n'y aura bien entendu dans la même
période aucune augmentation parce que
quand on baisse les cotisations et quand
il faut les financer on a deux
possibilités soit on fait les économies
aujourd'hui sur le budget global de
l'État soit l'on fait payer aux Français
sous forme d'impôt il n'y aura pas il
n'y aura pas d'impôt nouveaux pour les
français et notamment les plus modestes
et les classes
moyennesation du déficit parce qu'il y
aussi le trè déf alors alors là soyons
précis tant que nous ne sommes pas à
l'équilibre budgétaire il y a
augmentation de la dette de notre pays
et le chemin que nous nous engageons à
poursuivre c'est le chemin année par
année graduellement de baisse des
déficits publics le FMI d'ailleurs des
comptes à rendre à Bruxelles les 3 %
notamment on la on a des comptes à
rendre aux Français d'abord si on passe
pas outre Bruxelles la preuve on discute
avec Bruxelles mais enfin le FMI dit
lui-même à Bruxelles regardez le chemin
qui est celui de la la France est un
chemin qui respecte ce que vous voulez
peut-être même que ce que nous
présentons nous-mêmes donc bien entendu
moi la chose importante pour moi c'est
bien entendu d'arriver aux critères de
convergence c'est bien entendu d'arriver
à terme et le plus rapidement possible à
un budget qui soit en équilibre si nous
pouvions revenir à un budget équilibré
ce serait une formidable nouvelle ce que
je veux dans une période qui est
toujours une période de crise c'est que
d'année en année on constate une
amélioration une amélioration une baisse
de nos déficits public et ce qui serait
intolérable pour les Français c'est que
sous prétexte de desserrer ici une
contrainte même une contrainte qui les
intéresse l'on reparte dans la marche à
la hausse des déficits publics dans
notre pays et bien cela ça n'arrivera
pas et pour le reste vous n'aurez pas
attendre longtemps parce que dans le
mois qui vient les 39 milliards qui ont
été annoncés par le Premier ministre sur
la protection sociale sur les
collectivités locales sur les opérateurs
de l'État plus les 11 milliards pour
faire 50 qui reste sur je dirais
l'anarchie un peu de notre système de
prestation aujourd'hui sur lequel il va
y avoir un certain nombre de mesures de
justice mais ces mesures seront
annoncées de façon très précise dans les
semaines qu'il viennent et c'est
notamment utile nécessaire d'abord pour
l'information des Français mais pour
bien les convaincre que c'est l'État qui
fera des économies et non pas les impôts
qui seront sollicités merci Jean-Louis
gomau on va passer sur un autre thème
qui a été évoqué c'est la
décentralisation notamment Marion et oui
la nouvelle réforme annoncée par le
Premier ministre et bien c'est la
décentralisation division par deux du
nombreux de régions suppression des
conseils départementaux il faut
simplifier le millefeuille territorial
a-t-il expliqué aux députés mais aussi
aux sénateurs une réforme diversement
appréciée écoutez Jean-Claude godudin et
Jean-Pierre rafarin ne peut pas parler
me semble-t-il de la suppression des
départements pour supprimer les
départements il faut une réforme
constitutionnelle pour la réforme
constitutionnelle il faut les 3/5è et
visiblement le gouvernement ne les a pas
dans notre rapport il y a la défense des
départements donc le premier ministre en
prend une partie il ne le prend pas
complètement il y a une vision qui est
une vision contre les doublons éviter
que il y ait un Comité Régional du
Tourisme quand il y a un comité
départemental donc simplifier c'est
notre objectif si on veut sur ces sujets
avancés il faut placer le Sénat au cœur
du processus de décision cette réforme
territoriale ce Big Bang ne sera
possible que si le Sénat est en première
ligne le président socialiste des
département de France Claudie Lebreton a
dénoncé une réforme brutale est-ce que
la méthode est la bonne mais il faut
afficher une volonté pour l'instant ce
qui aurait été reproché c'est le manque
de crédibilité si l'on avait fait ce qui
est une annonce main de fois répété
cette question du milf territorial et
donc là manuel Vals n'a pas été brutal
il a donné un objectif il a donné en
même temps un calendrier que certains
ont jugé trop long la brutalité 20 pour
le département ça peut paraî on dit
c'est le prochain c'est pour plus tard
et c'est pour ça que vous voyez bien
qu'il ne peut pas être reproché de la
brutalité au gouvernement quand dans le
même temps on lui reproche de prendre un
temps trop long quelle est la réalité
droit de vous diche allons-y tout de
suite oui bien sûr mais ceux qui veulent
y aller tout de suite seront encouragés
à y aller tout de suite la date qui a
été donnée de 2021 est une date butoire
d'ici là les collectivités qui
souhaiteront s'organiser qui
souhaiteront opérer les transferts de
compétences qui souhaiteront opérer des
regroupement seront aidés ce sera
facilité et donc le point de départ
c'est maintenant le point d'arriver le
point où il y aura des décisions de
réorganisation c'est au maximum 2021
mais c'est c'est tout le contraire de la
brutalité est-ce que ce n'est pas un peu
une réforme opportuniste on sait que
2015 élection régionale élection locale
on annonce de mauvais résultats pour le
Parti socialiste est-ce que c'est pas
justement le moment pour vous de lancer
cette réforme non c'est le moment c'est
pas en fonction des élections c'est vous
savez on sait très bien que d'ailleurs
la perception des Français est très
largement interrogative parce qu'ils
veillent qu'il soit mis fin à ce mil fe
territoriale et en même temps quand on
regarde les études ils disent bah oui
mais nous dans notre région on a envie
de la garder etun Parti socialiste s'est
appuyé pendant longtemps sur ce
millefeuille territoriale sur ces élus
locaux mais bien entendu et dans le même
temps nous étions bon nombre à dire
qu'il fallait pour autant le simplifier
le rendre plus cohérent avoir une
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation
avec des compétences plus marquées moi
je suis heureux que l'annonce du Premier
ministre ce n'est pas tant une annonce
d'ailleurs de gain budgétaire d'économie
ça générera très certainement des
économies par la spécialisé
h
jeéarté pour un territoire qui mérite
d'êtreanisé de plus tout le monde a
l'air d'être d'accord sur la suppression
en tout cas de la moitié des régions
français ce qu'on a pas bien compris
c'est voulez vraiment supprimer les
départements je crois qu'à terme sur les
conseils généraux mais c'est pas très
clair sur les départements non les
départements l'organisation
administrative de la France en
département elle est quelque chose qui
est ancré dans notre histoire et donc la
question n'est pas tant de la
suppression des départements que de
savoir si le niveau politique des
conseils départementaux ce que l'on
appelait les conseils généraux sera
utile dans le temps si l'on s'aperçoit
ce qui peut être le cas qu'une grande
partie des dépenses qui sont les
dépenses je dirais d'infrastructure
générale que ce soit infrastructure de
formation mais d'infrastructure plus
lourde sont concédés aux régions alors
se POS question fin des départements
vousêes on le simplifie aujourd'hui on
peut dire ce ne sera pas la fin des
départements je pense que demain on peut
rester dans un département qui s'appelle
la corise sans forcément avoir un
conseil départemental de
corise ai et appartenir au grand
parisopole mais bien entendu bien
entendupart non je pense que ce n'est
pas la fin des départements la question
qui est posée c'est la fin des conseils
départementaux et le jour o on
s'apercevit que les intercommunalités
ont pris une partie des compétences en
les assumant mieux et que les régions
ont pris une autre partie des
compétences en les assumant mieux se
posera la question de se dire est-ce que
la coquille n'est pas trop vide donc ça
sera 2021 oui c'est une constatation qui
doit se faire sans brutalité passe au
mercredi suite et fins du
remanimement
et bien voilà ils sont 30 au total 16
ministres 14 secrétaires d'État qui
forment le nouveau gouvernement de
Manuel Vals à l'Élysée ça bouge
également tous les détails Jean-Baptiste
Daouas il y a d'abord ceux qui ne
bougent pas jeunev forazo est confirmé à
l'enseignement supérieur même chose pour
Cader Harif aux ancien combattant et
Frédéric cuviler au transport à la mer
et à la pêche il devra faire éipe avec
Solen royale dernière rescapé de
l'équipe héros fleur Plerin obtient le
commerce extérieur le tourisme et les
Français de l'étranger quant à Valérie
FOURNERON elle passe du sport au
commerce à l'artisanat et à l'économie
social et solidaire parmi les nouveaux
entrants l'arrivée la plus marquante est
celle d'arlem desésir en difficulté à la
tête du PS il a fini par accepter de
devenir secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
européennes total h parlementaires
deviennent secrétaires d'État dont si
députés Jean-Marie Len sera chargé des
relations avec le Parlement anque
Girardin du développement et de la
Francophonie Axel le maire Hite du
numérique Thierry Brayard des sports
soleneville des handicapés et de la
lutte contre l'exclusion et enfin une
surprise le rapporteur général de la
commission des finance Christian devient
secrétaire d'État au budget enfin de
sénateurs
la première était attendue Laurence
Rossignol sera chargé de la famille des
personnes âgées et de l'autonomie le
dernier l'était beaucoup moins André
Vallini espérait devenir ministre de la
justice il devra se contenter d'un poste
délicat secrétaire d'État chargé de la
réforme territoriale c'est lui qui devra
travailler sur la division par de du
nombre de régions je vous propose de
traiter du caslem désir un petit peu
plus tard moi ce que je voudrais
comprendre c'est en quoi est-ce que
c'est gouvernement de combat parce que
si on en croit le le sujet de
Jean-Baptiste doulas finalement c'est un
jeu de chaise musicale ça bouge pas tant
que ça ce sont les mêmes et on
recommence non d'abord il y a
aujourd'hui un nombre de ministres
restreints c'est-à-dire que la ministres
14 secrétaires 30and même le Conseil des
ministres ça va être 16 ministres 16
ministres qui vont avoir d'ailleurs un
temps qui va être un temps beaucoup plus
collectif et donc une équipe qui est une
équipe resserrée ensuite en Allemagne on
nous fait souvent la comparaison il y a
le même nombre de ministres il y a
encore plus de secrétaire d'État donc là
il y a des secrétaires d'État parce
qu'il y a des points sur lesquels il
doit y avoir une action particulière
sous la responsabilité des ministres une
équipe dont on ne fait pas table ras de
l'expérience de certains où il y a de
nouveaux entrants avec une nouvelle
énergie enfin très l'équipe de combat
moi je la vois je la vois là en
regardant ce gouvernement un
gouvernement très hollandais qui entour
manuel Vals bah c'est François Hollande
qui a réalisé ce gouvernement finalement
écoutez vous connaissez mal manuel Vals
pour penser qu'on aurait pu lui imposer
un gouvernement ce gouvernement c'est le
G gouvernement Vals 1 qui a été fait
avec le président de la République c'est
bien la démonstration d'ailleurs que je
vous faisais tout à l'heure qu'il n'y a
pas d'un côté le Premier ministre et le
président de la République et pour le
reste oui je vois aujourd'hui 30
ministres qui ont la particularité
d'être tous hollandais et d'être fidèles
au Premier ministre donc il a pas une
feuille de papier à cigarette entre
François Hollande et manuel Vals vous
pouvez toujours chercher en regardant
les uns et les autres avant mais non il
n'y a pas alors pas une feuille de
papier à cigarette entre le Premier
ministre et le président et le président
de la République pense qu'aujourd'hui il
c'est pour ça qu'il a confié la
responsabilité du gouvernement à Manuel
Vals qu'il est le mieux à même dans la
période après ce que nous avons connu
d'incarner ce que j'appelle la nouvelle
étape ce nouvel équilibre que nous
devons mettre en œuvre il y a une autre
nomination cette semaine Jean-Pierre
jouillet secrétaire général de l'Élysée
l'ami intime du président il fallait
recadrer la communication l'équipe
autour de François Hollande le président
de la République l' l'a dit enfin il
voulait en même temps participer
lui-même d'une nouvelle animation du
dispositif je crois changer faut tout
changer je crois d'ailleurs que le choix
de Jean-Pierre jouillet est un choix
s'il ne l'a pas fait dès l'élection
présidentielle c'est très certainement
parce qu'un certain nombre de Français
aurait pu être interrogatif sur
Jean-Pierre qui avait étaé dans l'équipe
précédente avec Nicolas Sarkozi il y a
eu un passage je pense que le Président
de la République a bien noté
qu'aujourd'hui rien ne faisait obstacle
à ça et quand dans l'opinion publique
cette question n'existait pas il avait
je crois une envie très particulière de
travailler avec Jean-Pierre jouillet
vous connaissez les liens politiques
même amicaux bien entendu mais qui se
sont fondés au fil des années sur un
parcours et des idées commune donc je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose de
la même façon que je trouve très très
intelligent et intéressant qu'un grand
fonctionnaire de l'État parce que
pierreen Pierre René Lema est un très
grand haut serviteur de l'État puisse
demain si c'est confirmé diriger la
caisse des dépôt parce que c'est un
outil public parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle souvent le bras armé de l'État
et qu'il est mieux d'y mettre là
quelqu'un qui a la notion du service
public que la notion d'autres intérêt on
va passer cette fois une nomination qui
a cristallisé les critique c'est celle
d'arlem
désir exfiltré du Parti socialiste après
la déroute aux élections municipales le
Harlem désire part vers le secrétariat
d'État aux Affaires européennes un jeu
de chaise musical moqué par la droite et
diversement apprécié à gauche écoutez
les réactions vous échouez dans une
mission importante l'animation du Parti
socialiste vous être nommé au
gouvernement c'est drement moral sans
compter que j'ai pas l'impression que
dans son cursus il a une grande
compétence des institutions européennes
du droit européen ou des affaires
internationales a pas desmérité patience
et longueur de temps font plus que force
ni queage r c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle je pense que c'est toujours un
honneur que d'être ministre ou
secrétaire d'État dans dans la
République il y avait incontestablement
des un dysfonctionnement on nétait pas
les derniers dire le parti ne pouvait
pas être uniquement la chambre
d'enregistrement de l'action
gouvernementale quand on vous dit prima
l'échec vous comprenez vous entendez non
parce que l'échec il est collectif et
j'ai toujours dit cararlem désir faisait
beaucoup trop Bou émissère pour que ce
soit crédible pour autant lui-même a
pensé qu'il fallait changer et que dans
le mouvement dont vous me parlez du
gouvernement tout à l'heure de l'Élysée
il fallait aussi changer et ça désir l'a
reconnu dès le lendemain de l'élection
municipale n pas réussi à la tête du PS
vous êtes
d'accord oui en tout cas il ne s'est pas
imposé comme il aurait pu s'imposer on
peut le regretter lui-même je pense peut
le regretter mais en même temps je ne
voudrais pas que à cette question là en
disant il ne s'est pas imposer on disent
qu'il n'est en fin de compte bon à rien
faire autre chose alors que on disait il
y a quelques mois oui il est pas très
bon ici mais il est très bon sur les
questions européennes parce qu'il a
toujours été ce choix il an parce que il
y a le choix qui a été fait par la
majorité du Parti socialiste a été
différent B ça question oui ben ça
aurait pu être un choix fait plutôt bien
entenduant c'est un des 30 députés
européens les plus absents non ça je je
je réfute cette idée il a un taux qui a
été un taux d'absentéisme qui a été plus
fort quand il est devenu Premier
secrétaire du Parti socialiste tout
simplement parce que c'est une fonction
qui est une fonction particulièrement
prenante mais il était à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg pour les votes importants
pour le reste vous pouvez interroger
tous ceux qui sont à Bruxelles depuis
plusieurs années ils vous diront que
c'est un des meilleurs spécialistes de
la mécanique européenne de la façon dont
les choses fonctionnent et de ce point
de vue- là je pense qu'il est
aujourd'hui content et soulagé d'être
dans un poste où il va montrer la mesure
de ce qu'il est ch c'est le choix de
quiem désir c'est le choix du Premier
ministre et du président de la
République vous croyez que le Président
de la République s'occupait pas des
affaires qui concernent le Parti
socialiste non il concerne des affaires
qui concne le
gouvernement de son parti quand mêmec il
a choisi un secrétaire d'État aux
Affaires européennes avec le Premier
ministre il s'occupe des affaires qui
concerne son gouvernement et la France
avec tous ces changements on a
l'impression finalement que le quinquen
de François Hollande il commence
maintenant ça vous avez tort de penser
cela parce que rien ne serait possible
aujourd'hui s'il n'y avait pas eu
l'action menée durant ces 22 premiers
mois par Jean-Marc herraud euh quand
nous parlambou quand nous parlons tout
non on ne chamboule pas tout on accélère
euh on infléchit mais en même temps on
persévère sur les dimensions qui sont
les dimensions essentielles et est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas pour pouvoir
persévérer et en même temps accélérer
avoir des choses qui repose sur la
confiance de l'opinion publique bien
entendu que le Président de la
République a pensé qu'il fallait
renouveler les
pour faire en sorte d'avoir un nouveau
regard des fr faç pour reprendre la main
un petit peu aussi mais bien entendu
mais enfin c'est quelque chose de
totalement normal que de vouloir dire à
des électeurs après une élection on vous
a entendu nous allons prendre en compte
que d'avoir un Premier ministre qui
incarne non simplement cette prise en
compte mais une nouvelle énergie c'est
usant d'être au responsabilité il faut
renouveler les équipes il faut mais
c'est des choses qui sont très normal il
reprend l'autorité la restaure
aujourd'hui avec moi je pense que le
président n'a jamais perdu d'autorité il
peut y avoir des interrogations chez les
Français sur le bénéfice de l'action
entreprise sur les résultats sur le
tempo du président de la République et
c'est pour ça que je n'imagine pas
d'ailleurs que le Président de la
République n'est pas pour projet de
s'adresser au français moi moi je ne
suis jamais il doit ou il ne doit pas
j'ai du mal à imaginer au moment où je
vous parle mais il a pris la parole dès
le lendemain des élection municipale
pour dire aux Français qu'il les avait
entendu et qu'il y aurait des décisions
ces décisions n'ont pas tardé elles ont
est annoncé dès le lendemain j'imagine
aujourd'hui qu'il y a un nouveau
dispositif avec cette amplification de
la politique de redressement mené et de
justice sociale j'imagine que le
président a pour projet de s'adresser au
français c'est peut-être un souhait ou
une envie ou en tout cas quelque chose
que vous savez puisquon parle du
président de la République vous avez
peut-être vu ce documentaire sur France
3 c'était lundi dernier dans la tête du
président de la République on en parle
c'est le plus de
l'bdo c'est documentaire signé France
Olivier gisberg que se passe-t-il dans
la tête de françois hollande voilà un
petit résumé proposé par Simon Barbari
moi président de la République j'essaiai
d'avoir de la hauteur de vue depuis 2
ans on ne compte plus les documentaires
sur François Hollande cette semaine
France 3 récidive avec une soirée moi
président dans laquelle on a pu voir ce
film du journaliste France Olivier
gisber que se passe-il dans la tête de
françois hollande on le disait faible
incapable de trancher dénué de car et
bien détrompez-vous c'est un maquiavel
mais un maquiavel souriant qui est
dépint ici mais comment vous dire il y a
deux François Holland au moment où on
parle celui qui vous regarde dans les
yeux qui vous dit oui oui on l'a dit le
coup d'avant qui dit ah oui oui tu as
raison je le note hein et en même temps
qui doit intimement savoir qu'il fera
rien de tout ça de ses débuts en
politique jusqu'à son but ultime
l'Élysée en passant par sa vie privée
les proches du président ne sont pas
avares en anecdote et tous sont unanimes
derrière cette apparente bonomie
François Hollande est un homme froid et
déterminé al je pense que que que
François Hollande son très de caractère
Mme la différence qu'on a c'est que lui
il a une ambition terrible voil derrière
un caractère très débonir très détaché
il a une très il y a une très grande
ambition une très grande détermination
avec une froideur terrible pour arriver
à cette à la réalisation de de cette
ambition mais ce qui faisait sa force
dans la conquête du pouvoir sa
discrétion et surtout sa capacité ING a
laissé du temps au temps a fait sa
faiblesse arrivé en
exercice peut-être le péché originel de
cequena c'est de pas avoir expliqué la
situation dans laquelle on était
clairement clairement moi j'ai commencé
à rappeler la nécessité de la de la
pédagogie de la crise dès
septembre
mais il me disait oui tu as raison tu as
raison faut le faire et puis ça se
faisait pas sans porter de jugement sur
sa première partie de quinen à l'issue
de ce documentaire une question nous
brûle les lèvres François Hollande
est-il vraiment un président
normal et moi la question qui me Brû
lesé lèves c'est de savoir vous le
connaissez très bien François Hollande
est-ce que finalement nous on connaît
mal vous peut-être pas il a une relation
particulière à ceux qui font votre
métier qui commentent l'actualité il a
en même
temps c'est très fort je je je pense
pour être très juste et vous dire le
fond de ma pensée que les Français se
posent la question c'est pour ça que ce
genre de de de de documentaire
particulier en même temps il y avait
quelques moments dans le documentaire o
on était dans la subtéité des unes du
point quoi mais ce ton un peu ban mais
en même temps a pu provoquer l'intérêt
parce que les Français je pense pour bon
nombre d'entre eux ont envie de
connaître mieux le président de la
républ il éé beaucoup regardé le
documentaire tout à fait tout à fait
c'est pour ça que je dis que cela relève
d'un besoin je pense que les Français
ont besoin bien entendu de suivre ce que
va faire le président mais ils ont aussi
besoin peut-être de mieux le connaître
et c'est de ce point de vue- là où je
peux avoir une forme de regret moi qui
connais bien le président de la
République je sais que quand on on le
connaît quand on discute avec lui quand
on a le sentiment d'avoir eu le temps de
l'écouter on est enthousiasmé par pas
l'homme que l'on voit aujourd'hui en
tout cas qui donne à voir en tout cas je
pense que il
mériterait d'être encore mieux connu par
les Français et donc forcément de faire
ce qui est nécessaire pour cela de
s'adresser peut-être plus directement à
eux mais quand on connaît François
Hollande on est toujours étonné par la
façon dont il trace le chemin par la
tenacité qui est la sienne par la
capacité à ne pas dévier d'objectif
quand il pense que ce sont les bons
quitte à ce que sa personne puisse être
atteint oui donc vous lui dites quelque
part dévoile-toi plus oui en tout cas il
y a besoin vous je sais pas si vous vous
voyez vous le tutoyez maintenant je le
vous voit bien entendu dès que nous
sommes plus de deux dans une pièce c'est
c'est tout à fait normal c'est le
respect de la fonction mais je pense je
pense que le Président de la République
a beaucoup à gagné à ce que les Français
le voient tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
parce que la capacité d'empathie qu'il a
et la capacité de réponse au problème
que vivent les Français c'est quelque
chose de très fort chez lui mais
François Hollande est aussi décrit dans
ce documentaire comme un maiavel un
maiavel sourian mais on décrit toujours
à ce niveau celui qui est arrivé j'ai
souvent tendance à dire quand je vais
voir des classes de CM2 et qu'elle me
demande toujours est-ce que tu veux être
président de la République je leur dis
mais attendez il y a 577 députés vous
imaginez l'Enton noir et donc est bien
normal que l'on qualifie celui qui est
arrivé là de maquabelle parce que pour y
arriver il faut moi je crois que quand
on regarde le processus de François hand
c'est un processus dont on dit toujours
mais est-ce qu'il aurait pu le faire
avant alors on décrit toujours après
c'est quelququ'un qui a pris le rythme
qui est arrivé aux responsabilités quand
il était prêt à arriver aux
responsabilités c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais pensé que tuer était la chose
essentielle en politique qui a toujours
préféré discuter convaincre rassembler
on lui reprochait quelqu fois
il a beaucoup de sang frroid bien
entendu et il en faut dans les
responsabilités qui sont les siennes
mais dans le même temps c'est quelqu'un
par exemple qui a toujours chercher à
rassembler et à apaiser avant même
d'être président de la République son
but ultime ça a toujours été
l'Élysée je pense que pour lui la
responsabilité publique et donc
forcément la première des
responsabilités était un bel horizon le
but ultime non je ne pense pas qu'il se
soit jamais positionné comme ayant un
but ultime la volonté d'animer une
équipe d'animer un parti d'arriver au
plus haut de responsabilité oui je pense
qu'il assume totalement cette idée que
il n'est pas là par hasard donc on
retiendra aussi que vous aussi peut-être
vous voulez être président de la
République en tout cas auprès des élèves
moi je veux en tout cas non je leur ai
toujours dit que je n'étais pas animé
par ce moême souhait mais que j'espérais
dans les fonctions qui étaient les
miennes aujourd'hui et demain prendre
une grande part à ce qu'est la politique
dans notre pays et la façon dont les
Français la voi merci Bruno lerou merci
Michell à la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine
merci